non-stop news I couldn't want to take a
moment to reflect john shares his
thoughts on the big stories in our new
series we're calling it reporter's
notebook such a great name for a series
for you John Dickerson this week he
looks at the zero-tolerance immigration
policy politics has become so tribal in
America that political conversations can
now feel like the equivalent of the
debate over at Laurel vs. yanny no
amount of shouting changes what we hear
this routine looked to repeat itself in
the debate over splitting the families
of immigrants illegally crossing the
border the president's tribe rallied
because the critics were the usual ones
liberals elites and supporters of looser
immigration the president blamed
Democrats that's the Democrat law the
Attorney General said the Bible approved
and the Secretary of Homeland Security
said the separations weren't happening
at all none of this was true and that
felt familiar also meanwhile the
children that were officially not being
separated from their parents kept being
separated from their parents but then
the pattern broke the president's allies
in Congress abandoned him religious
leaders even sympathetic ones were
appalled splitting families could not be
defended by splitting hairs in the
pulpits and at picnics purple
momentarily replaced red and blue people
whose elitism was defined only by having
children or having once been a child all
agreed but what did they agree on they
agreed to oppose splitting families the
basic unit of love that binds our common
human the Obama administration put
unaccompanied minors in cages too but it
did not split children from their
parents as regular policy that was the
difference Americans were objecting to
their government as the author of fresh
misery for ragged sleeved worn thin
fellow human beings whose only shield
against their misery was kinship and
hope do the right thing
treat these people as the human beings
that they are and breaking families
meant punishing children the stories
piled up the young boy whose mother had
sewn notes with the phone numbers of his
relatives in his clothes watching his
father being taken away the boy who
cried himself into convulsions and a
six-year-old girl repeatedly saying
her aunt's phone number after her mother
was taken away we're signing an
executive order in the end the president
had zero tolerance for his own policy
because even at a time of tribal
shouting the human tribe spoke louder
wow that's powerful that the president
had zero tolerance for his own policy
and to sum it up the way you did too I'm
telling you that the nun says sister
Norman said you can't look at those
little faces and not feel you have to do
something and know that this is just
wrong
well it was the it was the separation
that everybody you know that that moved
everybody to this story the separating
families and that it and it landed on
the on the on the children you know Gail
you started this week talking about the
Statue of Liberty and we're reminded
that people come to this country because
we are the country of certain rights
exactly rights of a constitution a bill
of rights I mean all of it they come
here for that very reason and so I think
this was offensive to people's
understanding about what America really
is yeah and you know we are gonna start
keeping count of how many kids remain
separated from their parents
the count today is 1842 we will keep
count you know it started with two
thousand three hundred and forty two as
of today 1842 kids still remain
separated and that's 1842 kids two
minuting okay you know in the hospital
nor when your when your baby's born they
give you a little bracelet with your
name and his name there has to be a
system that we can keep track and that
has not happened we failed these people
miserably agreed we will keep track and
think about that you were there on
Monday shining a light on this story and
the president reversed his decision days
later there are a lot of light shined